up  uh  just do a split screen so we can start  please  all right go ahead and ask your question  go ahead  it's the best we're gonna do right now  okay um  good morning would you please state your  name for the record  charlie roberts  miss roberts how do you know johnny depp  i managed his island in the exuma keys  in the bahamas for the past 15 years  miss roberts where do you live  i live on i live on the island and i  have a home in nassau and in long island  bahamas which i try to get to as  frequently as possible  can you please describe mr depp's  private island generally  my duties on the private island would be  to  maintain the  island the buildings the houses  logistics not included or limited to  provisioning fuel uh  gas groceries  just day-to-day operations staff  and kind of like an estate just in the  middle of nowhere  you